[Music]
to find the many
again
in the one
he sweated under
foreign Skies
to see the stars behind
the Sun
so space and time
[Music]
undone
reality
was undisguised
we found the many
in
in the one
[Music]
we stare at photographs but none could
show the mind
behind the eye
eyes or the Stars Behind
the Sun
[Music]
[Applause]
not with a sword
or knife or gun
a simple picture
severed ties
he found the many
in the
[Music]
light bends around us so we run
as gravity we classifies
the Stars we saw
behind the sun
[Music]
to see the world
beyond the skies
to touch the Mind
behind the eyes to find the many
in the world
he showed the Stars Behind the Sun
[Music]
or anyway retiring in the orphans
retirement will never be an option the
gruff gentleman with the cat who
understands what the numbers mean
remembers a bicycle ride when he was
younger the smoke of the cigarettes he
does not smoke kick at his lungs mixing
with the buzz of the booze he doesn't
have a drink a convivial pipe after the
ride into the country gave him such a
thirst and afterwards they lay on their
backs in the stubble staring up at the
stars together
all the stars
accountable as the words in the Bible
countable as the hairs on his friend's
head all accountable and that is why
they never truly touched the shadow of
prison or disgrace perhaps moving
between them like the shadow
of an eclipse
and
in another life
at another time
see the stars behind the sun he takes
his photographs fighting the cloud cover
becoming the thing that happened in
Principe when he proved that the German
was right that light had wait
[Music]
half a year after the armistice
popularizer but not courting popularity
somewhere a boy is Counting Stars some
when a man is photographing light
some when his finger Strokes the stubble
on another's cheek
[Music]
everything
is relative
all right
[Music]